c'est dur de faire des télés la partie
quand même pour une grande campagne de
promotion
c'est dur les télés oui c'est dur parce
qu'il n'ya pas de place n'a pas de place
pour l'artiste alors on se retrouve
confronté à des problèmes de choix qui
est passé dans des émissions qu'on ne
défend pas avec lesquels on n'a pas
envie vraiment collaborer pas ce que
j'appelle ça vraiment de la
collaboration
quand par exemple on passe à jean pierre
foucault sacrée soirée
on se pose des questions quand même non
mais écoutez c'est grave parce que parce
que ça parle moi j'ai envie de parler à
ce public là hein tu envie que qu'il me
connaît je suis en vue lui raconter les
histoires mais de passer à travers ce
biais là c'est très déformant donc c'est
compliqué et en même temps comme on
existe autrement parce qu at il
tellement le choix
c'est vrai qu'un jour c'était au début
tu vas chez collaro et il te demande de
chanter c'est l'époque de banana split
de chanter banana split et avec des mecs
à lui en fait ça ne faisait pas rire du
tout et a forcé à le faire non non ne
m'a pas forcée j'ai refusé je vais
t'acheter une banane à la fin quand même
oui mais attend il faut remettre les
choses dans leur contexte
c'est vrai qu'il m'a jeté une banane
mais de toute façon c'est pas la banane
que j'ai reçues qui me pèse pas ce que
j'ai fait la chanson comme je voulais
signalement il voulait me mettre autour
de moi des sites utilisent des
culturistes enfin des légendes son
équipe à billets en en champion
olympique parce que tu es un collaro sur
sur le sport et j'étais lui dire écoute
moi j'en veux pas parce que ma chanson
c'est pas de la kermesse et m'a regardé
il m'a dit mais ta chanson c'est pas du
claudel j'ai dit tu as raison mais c'est
ma chanson alors je parcours long et il
m'a laissé faire comme je voulais mais à
la fin bon il m'a lancé une banane et
alors c'est savannah niveau
c'est vrai qu'au début un jour tu allais
voir le patron de telles maisons de
disques et qui ont refusé d'avoir 3 % du
détail qui voulaient 5% et tu t'es mis à
pleurer dans son bureau il a accepté
finalement c'était un principe j'ai
refusé de signer à moins que ça ouais
parce que pour moi c'était très clair
très forte quand j'avais 16 ans mais
c'est bien mais c'était ça ma force
c'est je te dis pour ça qu'on vient des
vieux conséquent le temps passe on sera
money il faut pas se ramollir j'avais
bien raison à 16 ans d'être comme gts
que je défende et des choses bien tu
t'es pas bobo un mollusque un petit peu
par moment un beau roman c'est si non
alors